the Curan are the second largest ethnic
minority in Myanmar they've been
fighting for an independent state since
1949 before changing their demand in
1976 to one for greater autonomy despite
a ceasefire agreed in 2012 fighting
continues but in this part of Keun state
as it's now called quran community
leaders have created a sanctuary the sow
in peace park covers nearly 5,500 square
kilometers and includes villages forests
and wildlife reserves here the Quran
continued their traditional way of life
relying on nature for their needs and
practicing customary land management to
preserve the environment saw more hair
an internally displaced Quran has known
war for most of his life in the past we
had to run and hide from the Myanmar
army it was exhausting when soldiers
attacked our village we had to run
we took our food supply into the jungle
but when soldiers found it they would
steal it sometimes they would burn it
the village is remote but people here
seem content
no we live self-sufficient lives we
plant rice grow vegetables raise pigs
and chickens if me and my soldiers don't
attack us we will continue our life this
way but elsewhere in Canyon state peace
hasn't held sporadic fighting still
happens sparked by the Myanmar
militaries moved to upgrade a road
previously used for military operations
quran community leaders say villagers
are also concerned about the military
bases dotted around the parks boundaries
solution is easy just we draw you know
maybe a couple of Burmese army camps
allowing people to come back and
establish re-establish the lovely hoods
and some you know cementery and you know
kind of projects come in and see how you
know things you know moving forward
right and then you can replicate the
park is the first of its kind in Myanmar
indigenous led its founders say it's an
alternative to top-down development but
protecting it from encroachment will be
a challenge the park isn't yet
recognized by the government
Myanmar's democratic transition has
opened the door to foreign investment
there plans to develop the area in and
around the park including two hydropower
dam projects on the Souren River in the
current struggle to protect their
community and their way of life
they'll have to be prepared to take on
corporations to Florence lui al Jazeera
Yangon